If x-- and the operator here is
this x with a circle around it,
so maybe we'll call it circle-x.
If x circle-x y is equal
to x plus 3y, and x--
I'll call that circle-plus.
So it's not plus, it's
a different operator.
It's a new operation, and
we're defining it here.
And x circle-plus y is equal
to 4x squared minus y squared,
find negative 2 circle-plus the
quantity three circle-cross,
or circle-x minus 1.
So if we just break it down,
we use these definitions,
it should hopefully be
pretty straightforward.
So let's evaluate 3
circle-x negative 1.
So 3 circle-x negative 1.
Well, they define
that as whatever
is x plus 3 times whatever is y.
So this is going
to be whatever is
x, so that is our 3, plus
3 times whatever is y.
Well, that's going
to be negative 1.
So this is 3 plus negative
3, which is equal to 0.
So this whole part right
over here is equal to 0.
So our entire
expression simplifies
down to negative
2 circle-plus 0.
And now we can use this
definition right here. x
circle-plus y is equal to
4x squared minus y squared.
So in this situation, our x--
let me circle it over here.
Our x is negative
2 , and our y is 0.
So this is going to be
equal to-- it's going
to be equal to 4
times x squared.
So that's negative 2 squared.
4 times negative 2
squared minus y squared.
Well, y is just 0.
Minus 0 squared.
And 0 squared is
obviously just 0.
And so this simplifies to
4 times negative 2 squared.
Negative 2 squared
is positive 4.
So it's 4 times 4.
So it simplifies to 4 times
4, which is equal to 16.
And we're done.